[Music]
and we're playing someone from
azerbaijan very nice
fod
all right queen's gambit i want to mix
it up just a little bit and i want to
introduce you guys to a cool line in the
queen's gamut called the chagoran system
so far we've been playing exclusively
qgd i feel like mixing it up a little
bit let's play knight c6 which is called
the chagoran
i'll talk more about the origins of this
system after the game but essentially
the
zen behind knight c6 is very very simple
everything you do for the next five
moves
is going to be geared toward attacking
the d4 pawn
now you might be thinking about this and
scratching your proverbial beard and
saying okay well how how do we attack
the spawn like do we take on c4 here
well that doesn't look good because it
allows d5
but remember that attacking can mean two
things it can mean direct pressure or it
can mean indirect pressure you can be
attacking or pressuring things that
defend whatever it is you're trying to
attack ultimately am i explaining this
clearly so in this case it's the knight
of the queen well e5 gives up upon e5d
takes e5 guys
bishop g4 very good
bishop g4 you want to take the knight
ruin white's pawn structure and weaken
the d4 pawn
now there isn't necessarily any rush
with bishop takes f3
and
if i don't remember the theory here i
think it might be e6 first
but for the sake of illustration i'm
going to take on f3 and just show you
guys what happens
when you okay so e takes f3 is already
kind of inaccurate here
but it's important to navigate this
accurately with black now i know a lot
of you are attempted by dc thinking oh
after bishop c4 i win the pawn
but there's a flaw in that reasoning
after d take c4 i've already pointed
this out
do not forget that you've allowed what
nasty move yeah the correct move here is
either e6 or knight f6
yeah d5 d takes c4 d5
and if the knight slides over to e5
then white can keep tossing that knight
around alakine style with f4 bishop f4
so we play this
solidly with e6 defending the pawn
and as you'll notice white will be left
very soon with a very big weakness on d4
okay bishop f4
now another thing you have to do is
obviously reassess stuff that was
impossible on the previous move
very common source of blunders and
mistakes is
okay a move is impossible so you kind of
push it out of your mind
and that's what you guys are doing you
guys are reacting to what you think is
the threat of knight b5 but that's not a
threat
some of you are playing a6
but first thing to establish folks is
that knight p5 is not a threat
it can be defended in a variety of ways
one of them is rook c8
now we play d takes c4 because d5 is no
longer
a problem due to e takes d5
thank you four player chess
and now white is in trouble and he loses
a pawn there we go
now what should we take it with
well that's not a trivial question
because both pieces can capture but
in the interest of playing like a good
russian schoolboy
we would play queen takes d4 yeah the
interest of playing like a good russian
schoolboy we would force the queen trade
why are we forcing the queen trade
because both bishops are hanging
in addition to the queen trade being
offered
now we're not out of the woods folks
because we haven't developed our king
side we need to play very carefully here
and to make sure we're not allowing any
nasty stuff with knight b5
castle short okay
and we need to prioritize right you have
a situation like this
the top priority is to get our king to
safety
yeah kavita we were threatening a fork
on c2 that's why he castled
well bishop takes c7 as a threat we need
to defend against it
but you don't just want to go rook c8 if
you're already defending against it then
you might as well accomplish some other
stuff right
so we long castle and this should not be
a surprising move to anybody we make our
king safer
and we defend c7 when more can you ask
of a move
there was a reason i didn't like bishop
d6 by the way which was an alternative
now we have a chance to simplify the
position which will buy us more time to
complete our development who sees what
i'm talking about
we can simplify force a trade
give us another tempo
knight c2 knight c2 we take his bishop
eliminate the two bishop advantage which
is the only source of white's
compensation create a weakness on e3
and then purposefully attack this
weakness with what move
here simplification makes a lot of sense
bishop c5 very good
now think about where the knight belongs
and don't just
say f6 because that's where you usually
develop it actually think about where
you want this knight to be and what you
wanted to do
in the end game every piece must be
doing something you cannot afford
to
mishandle one of your minor pieces
well let's answer the second question
first what do we want the knight to be
doing
well presumably we want it to be
attacking this weakness on e3 and so we
can go either knight h6 or more to the
point is 97.
knight h6 some people like to be fancy
but the problem with knight h6 is that
if white plays g4 your knight's gonna be
shut down you understand what i'm saying
here if white plays g4 at least the
night has other routes it could take
it's like if you're booking a flight you
can book at the frankfurt airport or you
can book it through i don't know some
remote place in newfoundland canada with
one flight a week it's like
you got to prepare for your flight being
canceled
okay what now
has has our opponent has he taken the
sting out of knight f5
has he taken the sting out of it no he
has not he has not
even though it may seem like he has
because white has e4 now that's his idea
i assume
but now you ask yourself what's the
drawback of e4
okay well maybe it weakens some squares
what square does it weaken
well it weakens d4 let's put our knight
there that's an outpost
all right we could have played knight e3
but remember that knight could have
gotten trapped there i don't like moves
like 93 which which looked good on the
surface but if you look a little bit
closer you see that the knight on e3 is
stranded
we have to be patient here this these
end games are not won in
five moves or even in ten moves
we need to keep making improving moves
slowly but surely
rook d1 he's playing well by the way
okay
now we need to address a couple of other
issues in our position
which are annoying me the first of which
is the prospect that something bad is
going to happen down the c file you guys
are on the ball let's go c6 let's create
a little pawn chain so that anytime in
the okay knight a4 not dangerous at all
where should our bishop go in fact our
bishop has multiple
squares it could hop to
no not b5 because the bishop is hanging
bish should be seven yeah it should be
seven we could go bishop b6 and offer
the trade but why this should be seven
is perfectly good enough
now we're threading b5 as our opponent
is thinking
we are actively
figuring out ways
that we can further improve our position
who can name a plan or a short operation
that can allow you to further improve
your pieces or position just name some
moves and we'll make one of those moves
double rooks excellent you guys are
thinking the right way how about this
bishop where could it go
maybe it could go to f6 right you can go
on to a better diagonal where it could
support the knight
but
probably the most
uh flexible is to start by doubling
rooks and then we'll see
so some of you said e5 technically e5
has a drawback but i'll talk about that
after the
game so he found a knife drawback
obviously here we want to double
especially because it defends the knight
again we're threatening b5 notice that
and it's missed
that's it
good
just double check rook takes c6 knight
takes c6 nothing okay
boom easy
we kept our eyes open for tactics now
notice what i did there on the one hand
i was kind of playing the long game
okay here's how we improve our position
blah blah blah
on the other hand
i kept my eyes peeled by the way king b7
wins the game rook is hanging knight is
hanging and he can't take on b5 because
of backrank mate
but on the other hand i was keeping my
eyes peeled for tactical ideas
which piece should we take
bishop should we take the knight
no obviously not because then the rook
takes we should take the rook goodbye
rook takes d7 then we infiltrate take
all the pawns
actually rook d1 is even better because
we win the bishop why do we win the
bishop
what is the final move after king
spam it
bishop c5 yeah
dark squares
there we go we're over 16 we're actually
exactly 1600
very very good
so
the chagoran is one of those
systems that flies over the radar
i have one student who plays it it's
very dubious if white plays accurately
but it's not a bad
i mean it's like the baltic you know
it's like the album it's one of those
types of openings c5 here
i would call them like third tier or
even maybe second tier defenses but at
this level it's not a bad idea to learn
something like this and to have it
as a secondary opening
so chagoran defense was named after
mikiel chagoran who was really the first
very famous player to come out of russia
he lived from 1850 to 1908
and tremendous contribution to opening
theory in many different openings
the guy was amazing he started the first
journal
chess journal in russia
um called chess list
let me see if i can maybe find like an
inaugural edition of it and read read
from it yeah so you can see by the way
this is interesting you can see by the
way that
in the notation this is the 1870s and
the notations already modern
look at look at the notation this is the
first edition of chess list
um
games
match potter against tukertor french
defense 20 november 1875.
e4 d4 d5 we can read some of his
annotations
so this is jigoron's annotations like he
would analyze tons of new games nobody
had this in russia at the time
here also possible is knight c3
so you can see how much how much
analysis there is the guy was serious
studies
scotch game
all of this he did himself
on his own
yeah look at how much analysis there is
and modern notation
black takes three pieces for the queen
but in his cramped situation must lose
anyways back to the game the chigorne
was kind of an og
he analyzed a lot of openings he read a
lot of opening articles and among them
was the chagoran queen's gambit yeah
okay so i will delve into the theory in
modern times it's considered that knight
c i think knight c3 is supposed to give
the biggest advantage
dc d5 so this idea basically kills the
kills the fawn and the chicagoan
but after knight f3 bishop g4 you get a
very fun line so if c takes d5
this is the one thing i will show you
guys you don't play queen takes d5
because of knight c3 this is
s-h-i-t
t5 etc what do you do here who can tell
me
what do you do
bishop takes knight
if d takes c6 you take that pawn with
your bishop and you're fine
and if g takes f3
then you play queen takes d5 attacking
d4 forcing white to spend a tempo to
defend it and the main line goes e5
knight c3 bishop b4
and then you get this fascinating
position where white has two bishops
black has two knights but white is this
insane pawn structure black castles
queen side black is worse in this main
line but it's really really interesting
so
you guys are welcome to explore this on
youtube
on your own make an analysis board use
opening explorer
um
and that's just like a plea to people
who are like well i don't know what to
do i don't know how to learn this
opening well first of all you want to do
a youtube search
but if there's no material just create
an analysis board on chess.com use
opening explorer
and just like figure out
you know what the theory is and try to
understand it
so here after bishop f3 yeah ef is the
main move actually
okay so
where our opponent went wrong is in
playing bishop f4 here this is a bad
move
um apparently white is supposed to play
c d e d
and now bishop b5 which makes sense this
is a lot more aggressive
and you're threatening to remove the
knight which is the main attacker of d4
and white is slightly better here as
well
but once bishop f4 happened we play dc
a lot of you were scared of this it's
not scary for many
reasons could somebody name one of them
other than rook c8 and rook seat is not
what we would have played what would we
have played here
this should be 4 check very good
because knight knight b5 exposes this
diagonal ziptiff thank you for the sub
if k2 we can always just play bishop a5
and use the bishop to defend the pawn
yeah we can play bishop d6 absolutely
but that's not the best move i mean
would you rather keep the pawn and force
the king onto e2 or allow white to win
the pawn back like this
no the move is bishop before check
by the way the same idea happens in the
jabbawa london which i play
knight c3 bishop f4
there is a line where white plays knight
b5 and here black has knight a6
but one of the most viable systems is
bishop before bishop a5 just remember
this concept
okay
so
once we take the pawn white is worse i
mean here white just down a pawn
and
our opponent could have improved at
several moments bishop e3 is really bad
um probably white should play something
like rick8d1
when
white has certain compensation for the
pawn and why does two bishops active
position we would have to be careful
probably we would get our knight out you
know and the game goes on rook f1 and a
bishop e5 something like this i'm not
too interested in analyzing this end
game i just think black is better but
white has something for the pawn
bishop e3 allows the simplification now
there's no longer any compensation in
fact white
is the one suffering on top of being
down upon
why was his undoubting his pawns worth
the tempo
wait what do you oh why did we spend the
tempo to undouble his pawns
like why did we do this
oh because as i often say doubled pawns
is not how you should think of this his
pawn structure on the king side right
now is a lot safer
than this because white has a very clear
weakness on e3 now
also we remove a very important piece
the the light script bishop is sort of
overseeing the board does that make
sense
so by removing it we are leaving him
with his other bishop which is ah
staring at biting on granite
and the rest was pretty easy i mean
white could have defended much more
resiliently
but
okay here he blundered
but we would go rook d8 we would start
pushing our king side pawns i mean this
is just terrible for white
was knight e3 followed by rook d2 good
maybe so i didn't play 93 because i
didn't want the knight trapped
so there's a question about this oh
white is a beautiful move here no it's
not good and white is a beautiful
refutation
what do you have to notice here it's
chigorian
you got it except i instead of a
look at this notice this x-ray
okay
knight b1 amazing
knight b1
knight b1 and black is busted you can't
you can't hold all of your pieces at
once
like you can try bishop b4 which is kind
of funny but it doesn't work
does that make sense bishop b4
you would not do this
no no no you would play rook takes
knight
one second
here we go perfect example look at this
2100
out playing a gm and then blundering
exactly in this way watch
so this is dragon kasich grand master
from i think montenegro playing a
tournament 2005. look at this position
look at how this 2100 has outplayed the
gm and 18 moves
just look at this
but what does he do
the guy says margetta says oh okay let
me take the bishop
and let me infiltrate the second rank
how
good does this look this looks winning
for black but
what did he miss
what did he miss
he forgot to look for the x-ray knight
b-1
bingo
that's it i mean you have to give up the
exchange and he lost
right so
these ideas are
important
x-rays nightmare retreats that stuff
[Music]
you